normally it's the FBI on the side of
prosecutors offering deals to potential
criminal witnesses tonight the former
number-two man at the FBI is seeking
immunity for himself
Adrian McCabe wants the protection in
exchange for telling Congress what he
knows about Hillary Clinton's emails
also tonight the new report taking issue
with the former head man at the bureau
and how he did his job chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has details on these astounding
developments good evening Catherine
thank you soon in the inspector
general's report puts director Comey's
leadership style under the microscope
with the Inspector General exploring
whether Comey went beyond his
authorities in July 2016 when he
publicly discussed the Clinton email
investigation and recommended against
criminal charges a responsibility that
fell to his boss at the time Attorney
General Loretta Lynch Comey has since
explained that Lynch's Arizona tarmac
meeting with Bill Clinton
just days before Hillary Clinton's FBI
interview from his handling classified
information was a game-changer in
addition to other intelligence that
implied Lynch would not let the email
investigation go too far that
intelligence is not public and it's
reliability unclear on Fox the former
director seemed to choose his words
carefully about Lynch well actually I
think we're both telling the truth I
never went to her and said Loretta I
think you should recuse yourself my
problem was she had already announced it
publicly that she wouldn't and that she
would accept my recommendation and so at
that point what do I do and I decide at
that point I got a step away from her in
a separate development Fox News confirms
that former FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe who worked directly under Comey
wants a special status if he testifies
on Capitol Hill
it's called use immunity and it means
McCabe's testimony cannot be used
against him in a criminal prosecution
the inspector general found that McCabe
lied under oath and made a criminal
referral to the US Attorney here in
Washington DC for lying to federal
investigators this morning a senior
Senate Republican on the Judiciary
Committee recommended against a deal to
secure McCabe's testimony we really need
to get to the bottom of what happened in
FBI during the cold years where
apparently there was misconduct going on
which i think is really important is the
finest law enforcement agency in the
world and we need to clear the air and
so I think giving mr. McCabe's cover for
immunity would be a mistake
cabe's lawyers said quote McCabe is
willing to testify but because of the
criminal referral he must be afforded
suitable legal protection adding that if
he were unable to get such a deal McCabe
quote will have no choice but to invoke
his Fifth Amendment privilege against
self-incrimination testimony is
scheduled for Monday before the Senate
Judiciary Committee that has the lead on
the inspector general's report but that
date could slip yet again Shannon yeah
we'll wait and see Catherine thank you
very much